nick clegg thank you very much for
agreeing to ask I knew selfish dick into
it would like to know a little bit more
about yourself that's okay so think back
I don't have a selfie stick we could ask
Oh didn't get but now is now I can see
it in action pretty embarrassing so when
you were 18 want to know what were you
like I mean what were the things you're
interested in uh when i was 18 i wasn't
i wasn't one of these people who kind of
you know it was obsessed with politics
in fact i found kind of a kind of
political student politics at that time
quite sort of shouty and i was like a
lot of students i didn't actually I
wasn't a hundred percent I knew who
exactly what was what in the world and
add as many questions I had answers and
I'd see these student politicians and
all the answers and what sort of
furiously shout at each other and
actually didn't sort of so what did you
do for fun oh I was quite I was going to
I was quite into theatre I did was
acting Tokyo amateur seriously I'm
effects and sports any note iment parts
i once i was once i think basically the
equivalent if not precisely the this or
third spear bearer in a in a in a
production directed by sam sam mendes
but wow yeah no no but I'm as I say my
part was was fleeting almost invisible
to the eye so chose the right career I
certainly didn't think I would have made
a career in acting like for sure thank
you very much well still thank you okay